Let's go next to our caller from area code
seven seven four, who's calling today from
774.
And where are you calling from, just as importantly?
Hey, David.
This is Max from Hop into Mad Max from Hot
Nilton.
You know, I've never been to Hopkinton, but
I do see the signs on the turnpike.
What is happening to Hopkinton like?
It's nice, it's a small little town, no small
ski mask town.
It's the start of the Boston Marathon is usually
how most people know by.
Right.
All right.
Very good.
Well, what's on your mind today?
Bobsleds, I know you've been stressing like
a lot about how, you know, we should, I guess,
get by in an office, more so to get Trump
out.
And I've always been told, like my whole life,
how, you know, everyone's vote matters.
But I've been told by those same people how
their vote might not matter if you vote independent.
And I understand that in the context of this
election year, you know, your answer is going
to be different.
I was wondering what your opinion is on that.
No, my my vote my my position is the same.
Every election, every vote matters, no matter
who you vote for or if you don't vote.
The question is, what is your political objective?
And does your vote support that objective
or does it take away from it?
So because we have a first past the post voting
system rather than single transferable vote
or other ranked choice voting systems, etc.,
if you don't like Trump and you vote third
party, you're helping Trump in a practical
sense.
Now, if you vote in a state like Massachusetts,
which will go to Biden, you can make the case
that you're not really helping Trump by voting
third party.
And that's a respectable case to make.
And then on top of that, what would be different
this time around is given that Donald Trump
is so likely to claim it was rigged.
I think it's important to try to run the score
up in blue states and in red states whether
Biden has a shot or not.
Let's try to build the largest number of of
just raw vote totals we can for Joe Biden.
So it's not I disagree with the idea that
it's different this election.
I think your vote always matters.
And not voting matters.
It has an effect.
And we need to understand what that effect
is.
Totally awesome.
I think that's a great answer.
Really appreciate all along.
Good luck.
I'm one more.
All right.
Thank you.
Yes, sir.
Very much.
Appreciate that.
Things looking very solid from the standpoint
of a million subscribers.
As of right now, we're at about 980000 subscribers.
So we may have very powerful news on that
for people sooner than later.